uh the situation was for for most of
most of our presentation anyway the
situation was that the search space
itself
was a linear space uh let's say rn
finite dimensional linear space
okay that's just what you happen to be
optimizing on
and that's a given then the choice that
we often make and certainly was the case
uh throughout the morning is that we may
decide that we're going to endow our end
with additional structure
namely make it a euclidean space give it
an inner product for example just you
know u transpose v the usual
and the reason we might decide to do so
is because if we do if the cost function
is sufficiently differentiable
then this is going to afford us very
useful concepts like the concept of the
gradient of a function
and the hassan of a function
and uh you have these uh you know
reminders at the bottom right of how
those things are defined
okay and uh once we have those concepts
then we can use them for algorithmic
purposes and define things like breaking
scent and newton's method
you know all of this is now uh fresh in
our minds
okay so so this is just one perspective
on what's going on there you start with
the linear space but then you decide to
make it a euclidean space
and the same thing is going to happen
when you're optimizing on a nonlinear
space
which
may however be
you know a smooth non-linear space
so in this situation
what you have is that you're trying to
minimize the function f
which associates a real number to every
point of a set m
and i'm going to assume throughout the
presentation that the set m is in fact
the smooth manifold
right and so it just means that it's it
may be non-linear but it doesn't have
any kinks and i'll come back to how
exactly we define manifolds uh
momentarily
and for now uh of course you you can
think of some of the examples that asha
brought up you can also just think of a
sphere and here it's important that i do
mean the sphere and not the ball okay
it's really about the shell
uh and and that's a smooth manifold but
if you consider the ball
uh with everything that's inside then
then i would not call that this smooth
manifold i would call that a maybe a
manifold with a boundary or something
and i don't wanna i don't wanna handle
boundaries uh in here
okay
now if
your search space is a smooth manifold
then you can decide if you want to you
can decide to add some structure to it
and make it the romanian manifold and
we'll go over what that means precisely
later on
and the reason you might want to do that
is because well very much echoing what
happens in euclidean case
if you do and if your cost function is
sufficiently differentiable we'll go
over all of that
then
this will afford you concepts of
reminding ingredients and romanian
headphones and with those objects you
can then again design algorithms like
gradient descent and newton's method
only in a romanian sense okay in a more
general sense i say more general because
of course more you know it will become
clearer hopefully
euclidean spaces are reminding manifolds
but there are many remaining manifolds
that are not euclidean spaces
okay now these ideas that somehow you
can use these you know reminding
geometry
to optimize on nonlinear uh nonlinear
spaces
this this is pretty much 50 years old
now in fact there's the
the seminole paper and the field
is by david luenberger from july 1972
um and so meaning next july these ideas
will be 50 years old all right
so
you know it's been around for a bit
however at the onset
of this journey to call it that
um
it was very much thought of as a sort of
a mathematical uh
some mathematical fanciness
um and the reason was that it was not
clear at all that you could actually
compute all of these geometric objects
that would come up in the description of
the algorithms that you know it was not
clear that you might actually be able to
compute them
in in concrete applications
now what happened later in the 90s is
that people from uh
control and numerical analysis numerical
linear algebra got interested
and they started working out that on
very many manifolds that do come up in
applications and i'll go over a few the
geometric objects that you need
absolutely can be computed efficiently
and robustly
using techniques from essentially
numerical linear algebra and the reason
for that
is that the manifolds that come up in
applications oftentimes are sets of
matrices
okay and and then the
the objects the geometric tools that you
need to compute
they end up oftentimes uh
it's the case that you can formulate
them as you know matrix factorizations
and and you know other things of that
sort
that's why i'll come back to that
but that's uh essentially the the gist
of it we're going to redo everything
from including space but do it now on
romanian manifolds
and in order for this to be a little bit
more clear what we're trying to do here
i do want to take some time and tell you
a bit more about what exactly is a
manifold again bearing in mind that you
know i'm sure many of you are very
comfortable with the notion already uh
but maybe not everyone and
let's let's all get up on the same page
here
all right so a first take simplistic
uh on you know what is a manifold would
simply be to look at a few examples and
non-examples and see what you know see
what they're like
uh so i claim that this here and that
here these two surfaces in r3
they are manifold in fact there are
smooth sub-manifolds off r3 r3 is the
the
embedding space and inside of that
embedding space there's a subset uh on
one hand a sphere on the other hand kind
of a hyperbolic and i claim that these
things are
smooth
and intuitively what that means is that
if i look very close uh you know to any
one point on those surfaces
it's going to be difficult to
distinguish this from just a linear
space they locally look flat
another way of stating that is that
locally around any point of those
surfaces
you can find a meaningful linear space
linear subspace that's a good
approximation for it locally
okay and in contrast you cannot do this
for the set over here
because for example if you look at the
kink region here right if you pick a
point here at the angle
it is not at all the case that you can
somehow pick one linear subspace
that is going to be a good local
approximation for the surface um you
know around that point and the reason
for it is that there's this angle
that you just cannot resolve with the
with just one linear space
okay that is the take one and i'll have
three takes
uh the second take
uh is perhaps a bit more more
informative is to actually look at
examples of actual sets
that actually come up in in applications
in data science to call it that
um
and you know which are
manifolds embedded submanifolds of a
linear space
and in all of the examples that we're
going to look at will be three slides
six examples in total
in all of these examples
you'll notice that the embedding space
will be
a linear space of matrices it's going to
be matrices of size n by p or symmetric
matrices of size n by n and one example
is just going to be vectors a special
class of matrices
and inside of that in
linear space of matrices is going to be
a subset of interest something that
comes up in a you know a natural way and
they're just going to have this property
that it's locally linearizable
although you know it may not be as
obvious as you know when we just look at
a picture and you can just immediately
see oh sure you know i can linearize
that
okay but i'll just claim that the sets
we're going to look at
uh have that property and then we'll
look at a proper definition later on
okay
so the first two examples you'll see on
each one of those slides there are
applications listed at the bottom
unfortunately i don't have the time to
go into them
but if you're a quick reader then you
can you know you can have a look at what
this is about i'll share my slides later
and we can talk um also
okay so the first uh example
is uh
the called the stifle angle okay so at
the top here
so here the embedding space is uh the
set of matrices of size n by p
and so they are tall and narrow matrices
okay so p is smaller than n
okay and the schtifer manifold is a
subset of such matrices
that is defined by
these
defining equations x transpose x is the
identity
and what this is encoding is simply that
the p columns of x
are orthonormal
uh in rn there are vectors of norm 1 and
rn and they're all orthogonal one to
each other
so the stifle manifold is a set of such
matrices and i claim that this is a this
is a manifold this is a smooth embedded
sub manifold of rn by p
and notice uh something interesting
about this
if you set p equal to one
then this is really just a sphere in rn
okay which is then also a manifold as as
we would imagine
and if you set p equal to n
then this is the orthogonal group
okay just the set of orthogonal matrices
of size n by n
which has two disconnected components
um one of them is uh the orthogonal
matrices we determine plus one
and the other one is the orthogonal
matrices with determinant negative one
if you just keep the ones with
determinant plus one then that's the
rotation group
uh also called the son
and in particular you know just to write
it this way because this is what
typically happens in applications
if you consider the rotation group in r3
so the set of three by three orthogonal
matrices we determine plus one
this um
is a smooth manifold again
and each matrix in that set corresponds
exactly and uniquely to one rotation in
r3 or one orientation in r3 and you can
probably imagine how uh you know this
comes up in applications in computer
vision and imaging and you know in other
situations
okay so if you need to optimize over
those sets you're optimizing on a manual
another couple of examples
the grass man manifold
is
it sounds a bit more abstract
it's not really
is the setup it is a set of subspaces
linear subspaces of rn
that have a certain given dimension d so
n and d are fixed here i start with rn
and let's say d is two and so i consider
all the planes
that pass through the origin in rn
and the set of all such planes is well
it's a set
and formally we can say that this is a
manifold it's a smooth set
now you can actually formulate this in a
way that is going to be embedded in
something all right so that you can
really picture it as being a subset of
matrices and you can do it the following
way you say okay
if i have a subset of dimension d and rn
then there exists a unique
symmetric matrix of size n by n
which is an orthogonal projector to that
subspace
right
to every subspace there is a
corresponding and unique orthogonal
projector to that subspace
so really the graph plan manifold which
is a set of subspaces
is the same thing as a set of
particular symmetric matrices which
happen to be orthogonal projectors so
the set of such matrices is an embedded
sub manifold in
the symmetric matrices of size and by n
and that's the grasp and manifold if
you've
if you've seen different geometries or
seemingly different geometries for the
grasman manifold before maybe as a
quotient of the shifa manifold or as a
quotient of the orthogonal group they're
actually pretty much all equivalent okay
you can make this very formal
okay
fourth example
if you are optimizing over matrices of
size m by n
but you're only interested in the
matrices whose rank is equal to r and
it's important i'm saying equal to r not
bounded by r
then that set again is a smooth embedded
sub manifold of the set of matrices okay
there are some intricacies to this one
it's a bit more complicated to handle
than others
but certainly um you know if you have
encountered optimization problems on
with rank constraints um
that which i'm sure many of you have
then then this this could be a tool um
you know
it can be useful in that in that
situation
all right third a couple of examples a
third and last couple of examples
uh and this one i imagine will feature
much more into briefs presentation and
the first one already featured in asha's
presentation is the set of positive
definite matrices
which is simply you know symmetric
matrices size n by n that's a linear
space but then among those
you decide only to care about the ones
that are positive definite here i do
insist on it being strictly positive
definite not just positive semi-definite
because i don't want to
have to deal with the boundary it's just
not something we're going to do here uh
but if you just consider the open set of
positive definite matrices uh that's a
manual
in a way it's a manifold for a stupid
reason just because it's an open set in
a linear space and well open sets can be
linearized
but it's not very interesting not very
instructive however if you turn it into
a romanian manifold in an interesting
way then things
well more interesting things happen and
you know we heard some about some about
it already we'll hear much more about it
i i
presume
um and then the hyperbolic space is kind
of the same story
um you can define hyperboloids in r n
plus one you know with this equation um
if you do that you just get some nice
smooth
sets in in rn plus one which okay fine
it's a manifold
but things really get interesting when
you endow this wouldn't you know with a
special romanian metric which i'm not
going to do here i just want to
highlight it for those two sets in
particular those two manuals in
particular um
you know
applications would involve you endowing
them with a special metric that makes
them hadamard manifolds and that's where
geodesic convexity really shines
and we'll hear more about that later
okay
all right so that's uh
the the intro longish intro
and what i'd like to do
starting now and um you know we can stop
for questions before that if there are
any what i'd like to do now
is actually take
a lot of time
to go over just the the basic technical
tools from differential geometry
starting really at the basics
differential geometry and romanian
geometry that we need for optimization
and in order for this to fit in a short
uh you know in a one-hour talk
i'm going to limit the discussion to
embedded some manuals of linear spaces
even though manifolds are more general
than that okay but this will make it
easier to give more concrete definitions
for everything uh so that's one uh
aspect the other aspect is that you'll
see i i will really focus everything on
just the definitions and the tools that
we need
for optimization whereas uh if you have
taken a differential geometry course
before i'm sure the focus was on very
different objects at least
you know at some point in the course uh
there's a
shift in in
interests between applied mathematicians
and pure mathematicians to
stay that way
right so before i jump into that uh if
there are any questions please let me
know i'm happy to to discuss
all right so if not
then let's
just get started with a
string of definitions but but i'll try
to provide a context and motivation for
all of them and and tell you why we need
them and what they're going to do for us
okay
all right so what is the manifold take
three
uh now with passion with epsilons and
deltas
we're going to say that a subset m
of a linear space e so think rd
is a smooth embedded submanifold of
dimension n so m will have dimension n
e has dimension d if the following is
possible and you can follow along on the
the cartoon down here so m is the circle
and it is a subset of r2
and i'm going to say that this set here
is an is smooth if i can do the
following
for every point x in the set
i can find
a neighborhood of x in rd okay in e
and a smooth map c
psi
which maps
that neighborhood u
to some open set in rd call it v
alright so psi view is going to be some
open set in rd the dimension here has to
match the one of e
all right in such a way
that well of course x
will be mapped to some point in there
but also i want the little bit of m
that is included in u
i want that to be mapped to well of
course a little bit of v
but that little bit of v has to be
straight it has to be you know a linear
patch if you will in rd
now i want to be able to do that in such
a way that c
is smooth
and you know in the usual sense for what
it means to be smooth in rd just c
infinity uh infinitely differentiable
it has to be smooth it has to be
invertible
and the inverse of c has to be smooth as
well and so we say that c is the field
morph
okay now if you can do that if locally
around each point you can deform the set
in such a way that it locally becomes
just flat
uh and you can do this everywhere um
maybe just not all at once then we say
that this set is a smooth manifold
all are smoothly embedded in linear
space
okay and and it's an interesting but not
entirely trivial exercise
to take this definition and to show that
this set here the cross does not satisfy
the definition right so if you have a
such a kind of a
you know non-smooth point like a
crossing point uh it's not possible to
find such a diffimorphism okay so
showing that the definition rightfully
excludes
uh such such sets
all right so that's what what a manifold
is i'm not going to need the definition
going forward but it's going to be good
to to see it uh at least formally at
least once
all right
and e is the embedding space
something that's going to be more useful
um going forward
is the following quick observations
one
you know
every set i mentioned before is a
manifold so sets of orthonormal matrices
you can find such different morphisms
fixed rank matrices as well
uh positive definite matrices well uh
this is true just because it's an open
set and you think about it the
definition from before
you know if your set m is just open in
rd
then for obvious reasons you can find
the b theomorphism that will map it to
an open set
okay
so
all of these guys are manifolds linear
subspaces are manifolds
open subsets off manifolds or manifolds
here i mean to use a subspace topology
okay open subsets of manufacturer
manifold that's useful to know
and also useful to know products of
manufactures cartesian products of
manifolds are also manifolds
all right now why do we care about
manifolds with
mostly we care about them because they
are linearizable what does it mean to
linearize a manifold it means that you
know you can approximate it with a
tangent tangent's base at each point
what's a tangent space it's a set of
tangent vectors so what's a tangent
vector
all right
so we can look at the cartoon here at
the bottom left
if you have your manifold m think of it
as a subset of uh i don't know r3 okay
and there is a point x on the manifold m
what do i call a tangent vector
well i would like for tangent vectors to
capture the idea
that if v is tangent at x then it means
that it's possible to move away from x
along the direction v you know at first
and at first order
uh but in such a way that they stay on
the manifold m
so stated but more formally
um i'm going to call v a tangent vector
if it's possible to find a smooth curve
c of t
on the manifold
or does it mean that the curve is smooth
well if you're a curve on a manifold
since the manifold is in a linear space
you're also a curve in the linear space
so i'm just saying you know you have to
be a smooth curve in the linear space
and you have to happen to
stay on the manifold all right
so
v is a tangent vector
at x
if you can find a smooth curve c of t on
the manifold
that passes through x
with velocity v
okay and this is what we see here all
right so c prime of zero is a tangent
vector
um
at x if c of zero is equal to x and c is
smooth
okay so
the other way around um you know for for
every such curve you get a tangent
vector but for every tangent vector is
going to be at least one such curve in
fact infinitely many uh then what do we
call the tangent space
well it's just going to be the set of
all tangent vectors
and if you think about the sphere here
it's not difficult to convince yourself
if you're not already that the tangent
space to the sphere at x
is going to be this you know linear
subspace of dimension two that really
just uh intuitively is the tangent space
to the sphere there um it's just the
subspace that's orthogonal to point x
okay orthogonal with respect to the
usual inner product in
in rn
all right
now the big thing
about uh smooth manifolds is that the
tangent space is defined in this way are
linear subspaces off e
and they will have the same dimension
and that dimension is what we call the
dimension of m
okay but if you pick just some you know
any fancy set like for example the cross
from earlier and you think about you
know what is a tangent vector according
to this definition for a cross
you will get a and then you figure out
what's the tangent space you'll get a
set which is not uh a linear space okay
so this is somewhat special about
manifolds
okay
in the particular case where your
manifold is defined through you know
some nonlinear usually non-linear
equality constraints like h of x equals
zero and under some conditions i'm not
going to spell out uh the tangent space
happens to just be the kernel of the
differential of the defining equation uh
and you can check that for the sphere
just you know you get the right thing
okay so this is often times uh the more
convenient way of figuring out the the
tension space of a of a manifold that
you're working with although most of the
time you're working with a manifold that
you know has already come up
and you just look up it's uh it's
tangent space in a book
all right
okay
now um tangent spaces are going to come
back often
the other thing is going to come back
often in the presentation is the notion
of smooth maps on and two manifolds
so how is that defined it's not going to
be too shocking
if m and m prime
are two smooth manifolds in two linear
spaces e and e prime
then something that you know
we might want
is that if you have a smooth function
that's defined in the embedding space
okay say for example you have a smooth
function defined on all of e a real
function depending on all of e and
formally
and call that f bar
and formally you say well i'm only
interested in the value of f
of f bar sorry i'm only interested in
value of f bar
on the manifold
so i restrict fbar to the manufacture
and formally i get a new function f that
is only defined on m
then
it seems reasonable that that we would
want that if f bar was smooth in the
usual sense
that then its restriction f would also
be deemed smooth
and in fact we're just going to pick the
definition in such a way that this is
essentially you know all smooth
functions are of that form we're going
to say
that a function on a manifold is smooth
if it's possibly if it's possible to
smoothly extend it to find some f bar
smooth on a neighborhood of the manifold
such that f and f bar coincide on the
menu
okay
all right now the big thing about that
definition
as you might expect as you might hope is
that um if you have two smooth maps on
manifolds and you can compose them the
domains are just right then the
composition is still smooth
question so here this movements you
still mean uh infinitely differentiable
i do
yes uh
how about like the optimization type
smoothness like or religiousness
properties
yes so so i i will not use the word
smooth in that sense uh so in the sense
of ellipses continuous gradients however
that notion uh will pop up uh much later
in the presentation when i talk about
reminding greed in the sense um it will
be a bit in disguise though but we can
talk about more about it more that at
that time yeah
okay
yeah
and so so maybe this is also a good uh
a good moment to also say i'm just doing
everything in c infinity because it's
convenient especially in a in a
presentation for everything to just be
easy
um but of course you know
much much of what i'll discuss can be
done with the
lesser notions of smoothness uh ck for
you know other values of k
all right
okay so what do we do with uh smooth
maps well we differentiate them
and what does it mean to differentiate a
map from a manifold to a manifold okay
so say you have a map f from m to m
prime
and i'd like to come up with a good
notion of what the differential of f at
some point x on the manifold might be
and then we think well okay
what is the differential supposed to
tell me
it's supposed to tell me what happens to
f of x if i push x a little bit in some
direction if i
if i have a point x on a manifold like
here on a manifold m and i push it
through f i get a point f of x and i'm
prime
now if i push x a little bit in the
direction of e along a tangent direction
v
then
something's going to happen to f of x is
also going to end up being pushed in
some direction and i'd like to know in
what direction and that's what i ideally
would call the differential of f x
along v so this is exactly how we're
going to define things we'll say okay
well if v is a tangent vector at x
then by definition of tangent vectors
there exists a smooth curve c of t that
passes through x with velocity v
the curve c of t
lies entirely on m
therefore i can compose it with f
and i'll get a function f of c of t
which is now going to be on m prime
since the curve is smooth and the map f
is smooth
and composition preserves smoothness and
f c of t is a smooth curve on m prime
and it passes through f of x
right just take t equals zero
if c of zero is equal to x
so that is a smooth curve on m prime
which passes through f of x it does so
with a certain velocity
and that velocity is just what we're
going to call we're going to define that
that is the differential of f at x along
b
right that's just a definition
now
when you come to that number
ah exactly right so when you when you
come to that definition in this way then
then you know uh
the the right question should be uh
indeed well is does this somehow depend
on the curve because if it does then
this is not a good definition all right
the left hand side here does not
uh involve any particular curve
but the right hand side does
so the claim here and this is actually
an easy exercise i'm just not going into
any of the details but the claim is that
this is indeed well defined does not
depend on the curve
and not only that but this operator dfx
is linear which is not immediately
obvious from the definition all right
but it is linear as you would presumably
want the differential to be
and also you have a chain rule uh so if
you have a composition of smooth smart
that's smooth and the differential of
the composition will obey a chain rule
so which is essentially telling you that
you know calculus and manifolds
um
will not be a um brain straining
exercise just all the things that we're
used to do uh you know just basically
still going to work
um now
one easy way to prove that claim
is actually to observe
uh this other
useful rule for calculations
which is
well if f is smooth
then by definition it has a smooth
extension f bar
it
can be more than one smooth extension
there's at least one smooth extension i
mean there's of always infinitely many
just pick a smooth extension f bar now
this is just a smooth map defined in an
open set in a linear space so you can
differentiate it in the usual way you
know with the limit and blah blah blah
now you'll get a linear map as we're
used to except it's defined on more than
the tangent space and the claim here
this is easy to check
is that if you restrict that
differential to the tangent space
you will get something that does not
depend on the choice of smooth's
extension
and uh it's actually going to be equal
to uh that operator right here
okay and oftentimes when you have a
function on the manifold what you
actually have is smooth extension you
just declare formally i'm only
interested in what happens on the
manufacture
but because you have the swiss extension
you can just differentiate that and you
get all the expressions that you need
all right
so that's the differential of the smooth
map
and now i'm going to introduce
one more object before we move on to to
reminding geometry and so far you know
there's no reminding whatever uh in the
mix
uh
the the additional tool that i need
is
a means to move around the manifold you
know i i want to in optimization i'm
going to generate sequences of points x0
x1 x2 x3 i'm going to hope that those
sequences will converge to interesting
points
but for this i need to be able to jump
from one point to the man equal to
another and retractions will be
you know our friend in that process
um so you can already imagine how we're
actually going to do this in practice by
looking at this cartoon at the bottom
right
one
fairly intuitive way to proceed is to
say if i have a point x on a manifold in
this case on the sphere
and i have a tangent vector v there
if i just do x plus v well
usually that's not going to be on a
manifold anymore unless it's linear
however maybe i can project x plus v
back to the manifold with something
called metric projection just find the
closest point on the manifold 2x v
that's one possible choice i do want to
insist here it's not at all retractions
of that form but certainly if you're
asked to move around the manifold and
you know you don't know anything about
any of that uh presumably you know
everyone would come up with it this way
it's kind of intuitive to do this
um
so you can do this on many manifolds by
the way so of course if your manifold is
linear then just do x v and then you're
done if you are in the sphere you can do
x v and divide by the norm this will
bring you back
uh if you are on the set of matrices
with fixed rank then x and v are two
matrices you can add them up and then do
a truncated svd to project back to the
you know rank r matrices with some
caveats here but but essentially this is
what um
you can do this okay so all of these are
examples of metric projections and i'm
going to call them retractions right
after i define what the retraction is
okay
now
what this
object what this map r is going to do
is it's going to take as input a point x
and a tangent vector v at x
and it's going to transform that into a
usually new point on the manual
so the domain of r is going to be this
thing here which is called the tangent
bundle
it's a set
and every element in the set is a pair x
v
where x is appointed in the manifold and
v is a tangent vector there and that's
it the tangent bundle is just and
nothing but
the set of pairs of that form a point
the tension vector there this tension
bundle
now a retraction
is going to be a
map
however is going to be a special map
so i just left the blank here we'll come
back to this
a retraction is a
map
r
which takes as input
a pair xv
and produces its output a point m on the
manufacture so x v to r
and it should have the following
property
that you can create curves with a
refraction why well because the output
of the retraction is the point on the
manifold so if you retract a family of
things you'll get a family of points in
the manifold okay so you can create
curves
with a retraction
and what we require
is that if you retract nothing okay if
uh
the you you retract zero times v
uh then you should not move so
if you start retracting at x you should
create a curve that passes through x
and the second thing is that the initial
velocity the initial direction in which
you're moving should match the direction
that you were given see in other words a
retraction is going to be some kind of a
you know a map of this type that will
generate curves that pass through x with
a given velocity you can imagine how
this will be useful for reminding and
grading this for example where i'll be
at a point
i'll have a gradient that i still need
to define that's going to be some kind
of a tangent vector and i'll want to
move away from x along the negative
gradient direction okay we'll use a
retraction for that okay
now ideally
i would want for this choice
uh this retraction choice to be smooth
and to make sense of that i need r to be
a map from a manifold to a manifold
because you know that's the best
definition we have for now is
the definition for a map to be smooth is
when it goes from one manifold to
another
um and
you know the
fact here that is helpful is that the
tangent bundle is a smooth manifold if
you have a manifold its tangent bundle
is a manifold and so it makes sense to
say i want the retraction to be smooth
right hopefully this makes uh this makes
sense
all right so that's retractions
that's
all we had to do for just basic
differential geometry just the notion of
things that are smooth and calculus with
them
uh if we want to
go further and develop algorithms for
optimization manifolds then it's
convenient i'm not saying it's necessary
but certainly convenient
uh to add more structure and to define
the notion of reminding manifolds
oh okay
now
um
this is actually just going to take one
slide to define there's not much to it
but it's it's good to see this at least
once
when we went from rn
from just bare rn to euclidean spaces we
did so by defining an inner product on
rn
okay
now inner products are defined in linear
spaces manifolds are not linear but
manifolds are linearizable at each point
all right
so the idea here is going to be the
followings okay at each point x on a
manifold
there's a tangent space txm
txm is a linear space
so formally
i can define an inner product
i'm going to index with x because now
there's going to be many
i can define an inner product on txm
just a
you know bilinear symmetric positive
definite map form
on on txm okay it's just very formally
it's a linear space to find an inner
product there do this for each point x
now
we'll say that if the inner products
vary smoothly with x and the blank here
is that because i need to explain what
that means
if the inner products vary smoothly with
x
then
we see that they form a romanian metric
and it's always the same idea that we
want things to be smooth
um
all right so a reminding metric is a
smoothly varying choice of inner product
on the tangent spaces
any remaining manifold is just a smooth
manifold with
a romanian metric
okay that's it
now what does it mean
uh that the inner products very smoothly
with x uh well i need one more concept
to make this uh there are many ways to
answer that question but let me just go
with the one that fits in this amount of
space um
and for this i need a new you know just
a new object but it's not going to be
too shocking and we'll need it again
later anyway
what is a vector field in rn
it's just it's a map that to each point
of rn associates a vector in rn
okay
what's a vector field on a manifold it's
a map let's call it v
which to each point x of the manifold
associates a tangent vector at x
so
the you know the output of the vector
field formally is going to be a pair x v
in the tangent bundle
where v is going to be tangent at x
all right
and because v is a map from a manifold
to another manifold extension bundle
it makes sense to say that the vector
field is or is not smooth just using
everything we've defined so far
good
so then how are we going to define the
fact that inner products vary smoothly
well here's one way it's kind of neat
um we'll define this why we say okay
pick two smooth vector fields arbitrary
just two smooth vector fields in a
manual u and v
now at each point x
i now have two tangent vectors right i
have u of x and v of x or two tangent
vectors at x
okay
what can i do with potential vectors
i can take their inner product because
on each tangent space i have an inner
product so i can take their inner
product
i'll get a real number
so
from the two
smooth vector fields i created a scalar
field just a real function on the
manifold and that function
may or may not be smooth
so we're just going to say
um that if every time i pick two smooth
vector fields and i transform it in this
way i get a smooth scalar field
then
we will say okay well this seems to be a
nice smoothly varying choice of inner
products
you get to be called the romanian metric
that's it
all right so that's the remaining
manifold
i want to highlight something
here uh just for the you know just this
question of where structure comes from
um
is that
a manifold
stifle manifold instead of positive
definite matrices
can always be endowed with infinitely
many different remaining structures
but the optimization problem that you
start with it's not defined you know it
does not come with a romanian structure
it's not part of the problem definition
you just had a set and a cost function
and that's it
so
we choose a metric but the metric we
choose the remaining metric we use is
something that we do for algorithmic
purposes and this you know it came up in
aschas presentation already quite a few
times and it's going to come back into
its presentation as well
um so the choice of metric is really
something different algorithms and it's
in the same vein as when we
pre-condition in numerical linear
algebra we just choose a convenient and
and a fruitful representation of things
so that computations will will you know
work out more nicely
now in the same way that in numerical
linear algebra we know there are many
problems where if we precondition life
will be better but we don't because it's
difficult to come up with a smart
preconditioner it's kind of the same
business and reminding optimization
sure it would be nice if you can come up
with a nice reminding structure
specifically tailored to your problem
but oftentimes you just use the
remaining structure that's convenient
and i'll talk about that a little bit
more in the next slide
um
and uh you know
then you work things out uh separately
okay but it's good to remember that you
could in principle uh be like a lot
smarter about all this
okay
all right so what is a
a convenient choice of a romanian metric
on a manifold embedded in the euclidean
space
well there's this notion of reminding
which which goes as follows
it says okay
if i have a manifold m
embedded in the euclidean space e
r n for example then e is equipped with
a
metric euclidean metric one inner
product which is defined everywhere okay
in all of rn for example
now the tangent spaces of the manifold
are linear subspaces off the embedding
space
and therefore formally i can take the
euclidean inner product and just
restrict it to each individual tangent
phase every time i do that i get an
inner product just defined on that
particular tangent space
okay and then you know you can you get
to write something like this because if
you and v are tangent to m at x then
there are also vectors in the embedding
space just because it's a subspace
all right
now um it's not too surprising and it's
very easy to show to confirm formally
that this choice of inner products is a
remaining metric
and if this is the remaining metric that
you choose which often times people do
because it's convenient we'll see again
uh then
the manifold you get the remaining
manifold you get is something we call
the rim a romanian sub manifold of e
and it's important to remember that the
remaining submanifold is not just a sub
manifold that happens to be romanian
specifically this remaining structure
okay
all right
good so we have manifolds we have smooth
functions and manifolds we know how to
differentiate them
we have retractions we can move around
we have
now remaining metrics and the whole
reason we build romanian metrics at
least in the context of optimization
is because we want to get to gradients
and hessians and those we want to get to
algorithms
okay so what's the gradient what's the
remaining gradient of a function
well remember the definition of gradient
of a euclidean function
okay which you have here at the bottom
right and you see it's defined with
respect to the euclidean inner product
in terms of the the directional
derivatives of the function
with the differential of f so on
manifold is going to be the same thing
say okay
a smooth function f on the manifold
then its gradient its romanian gradient
is going to be a vector field we'll
write it grad f
which is defined in the following way so
grad f of x is here
this is a tangent vector at x okay since
grad f is a vector field grad f x is a
tangent vector at x
and it is uniquely defined by the
property that if i take its inner
product with any vector v in the tangent
space at x i'll get a real number and
that real number is equal to
the directional derivative of f at x
along v so it's just uh the grad f x is
the wrist representative of the
differential of f if you will
okay now i claim
uh that this is a well-defined vector
field that's very easy to check
i also claim that this is a well-defined
smooth vector field which is
well um
it takes more work to actually check
that but if it's true because if you
have a smooth function it's gradient is
a smooth vector field
okay in practice you often need to
compute this if you're actually going to
run an algorithm
um in the special case it's a special
case it's a frequent special case let me
highlight it where m is a remaining
submenu for the euclidean space okay so
the thing i just defined which is just
take you cleaning inner product you
restrict it to all the tangent spaces
you get a special metric
in that particular case
um
you can compute the remaining gradient
as follows okay if f is smooth then it
has a smooth extension f bar it has many
just pick one
now f bar is a nice smooth function
defined in an open set of rn for example
okay
i can compute this grade the usual
euclidean gradient the definition is
here we all have our tricks to compute
gradients
you get something a vector
usually not a tangent vector there's no
reason for it to be a tangent vector
okay f bar does not know anything about
the manifold really
but if you then orthogonally project the
thing you got to project x is orthogonal
projector to the tangent space at x well
then of course you get a tangent vector
and the thing you get actually is the
remaining gradient
okay but it's a special case
however it's an important special case
the other thing i want to highlight is
again
usually in applications it's not that
you have to come up with a smooth
extension usually you have f bar
and then you just formally say i'm
interested in the restriction blah blah
blah okay but usually you have f bars
you differentiate in the usual way you
project you have the remaining grid
you're done
okay that's the idea
okay that's gradients what about
hessians
well um i'm not going to give you a full
story here because it's actually it
takes a lot more work to define
reminding hesses but let me highlight
why
or or you know at least where does it
block at first
and and then i'll i'll show you a
sort of a way around it but but
okay we just don't have the time to go
into details here
what should the reminding hessian of a
function f be
well um the remind the hessian you know
in the euclidean case anyway the hessian
measures
uh it's kind it's the differential of
the gradient really it tells you how the
gradient varies if you push x along some
direction
so we want the remaining hessian to be
kind of the same thing if you want the
remaining hessian of f at x
to be a linear map
ideally a symmetrical linear map because
that's what we have in rn
from the tangent space to the tangent
space okay it has it has to be defined
on the tangent space because i can only
push things along tangent directions
and if i want it to be symmetric well
the codomain better be the same as the
domain so it has to be from attention
speed to the tangent space all right
and i wanted to describe gradient change
so another way to say this is ideally
i would like for the hessian of f x long
v
to be something kind of like but not the
question mark to be something kind of
like the differential of the gradient of
f at x along v okay
this actually makes sense you can write
this that this is well defined y
because the gradient is a vector field
and a vector field is just a map from a
manifold from a to a manifold and we can
differentiate maps from manifolds to
manifolds and smooth
so you can write this down it makes
sense
unfortunately it's not a good definition
of a hessian why
because in general the thing you get
from that you know
thing
is just it's not a tangent vector so
you'll get a linear map from the tangent
space yes but the codomain will not be
the tangent space so there's no chance
that it's going to be a symmetrical
linear map meaning you won't have a
notion of you know a hashing that is
positive definite or negative definite
blah blah which are all very useful in
optimization okay so this is a no-go
um the
the proper way of going around this
issue uh like you said would take a
while but you can do this what you need
is actually new
notion of derivative four vector fields
and different in differential geometry
it's called an affine connection
on each manifold there are many i find
connections it's just ways of
differentiating vector fields
among all of them
if you're on a reminding manifold there
is a unique affine connection which has
very special properties
um you know that are well attuned with
the remaining metric
and if you pick that connection it's
called the reminding connection
and if you apply that to differentiate
the the gradient it's called the
covariant derivative then you get what's
called the reminding hessian right so
these are all things you can define
properly
for computation let me just you know
flash the formal line and then go
forward
in the particular case
a very mining sub-manufall of the
euclidean space
okay same as before where you had uh you
know the gradient which is a orthogonal
projection uh well in that particular
case what you need to do is you compute
this and say oh it's not tangent but
just let's just project it to the
tangent space and it's actually you know
the right thing to do except there's a
formal way of
explaining why that is
if you work this out you'll see that
there are some terms that capture the
the the extrinsic curvature of the
manifold and there's some correction
terms and what okay let's move on
okay
um i'm not going to go through this like
i said i'll share my slides this is an
example very simple optimization problem
on a sphere where everything is computed
or you have you know explicit
expressions that you could easily put in
a computer i just you know if you want
to play with this and see you know check
that you everything clicks then you can
look at this at this example
okay
all right
okay
so finally there's going to be some
optimization in this intro to
optimization on smooth manifolds uh
we're just going to look at um you know
a couple algorithms i do see that the
time is short so i'll go for the
uh you know i'll go for the essentials
um the idea for building algorithm is
going to be the the following
um it's always going to be hopping
around using a retraction so you'll have
some point x k
at x k you'll pick a tangent vector sk
you retract it it gives you a new point
x k plus one
and then you go again okay so what's an
algorithm on a manifold it's a way of to
pick tangent vectors s k
and uh well bearing in mind that the
retraction is also something that you
choose you know as the user or the
algorithm designer you know whoever you
may be
okay so what's an example of an
algorithm well reminding gradient
descent just says okay let's pick the
tangent vector to be the negative
gradient with some step size tk which
you choose with the line search
business as usual
what is newton's method
well um
you know if you remember newton's
equation from euclidean case it's just
the same thing and for the same reason
really
you just say okay um the hessian is a
linear map from the tangent space of the
tangent space
the negative gradient is the tangent
vector
in that
in that tangent space
let's solve this linear system of
equations in the tangent space you can
do this using matrix for eq uh solvers
for example conjugate gradients
um
the you know if the hessian is positive
definite sk is uniquely defined retract
that uh that's newton's method on the
manufacture
how do you analyze those algorithms how
do you make sure they behave well
well the the essential is just to bring
things back you know to massage things
until um
you can just work with the analysis you
know from euclidean space
and the way to do that is just
rather a tool of choice to do so
is to observe that really what you need
is to understand how is the value of f
at x k plus one going to behave
so if i want to know what f x k plus 1
is i need to know what is f of the
retraction at x k of sk
so i need to understand how does the
composition of f with the retraction at
the point behave
i need to understand what this guy looks
like
but f composed with the retraction at x
that's just a function in a linear space
okay because the retraction at x it it
eats up a tangent vector so this is
really a real function defined on a
linear space in fact on the euclidean
space
and this thing has a euclid has a tailor
expansion
and up to some technical points that i'm
uh
you know
omitting here uh the taylor expansion
looks exactly like what you might expect
except it's using our remaining concepts
we have the reminding grading the
remaining inner product the remaining
hessian and now that you have a taylor
expansion
uh you know if you remember uh from just
this morning how we analyze green
descent how we analyze newton's method
you can imagine how having this tool at
your disposal will just allow you to to
make things go through
okay
um
okay i'll take a couple more minutes for
uh for this slide
if you were you know wondering about
proving global convergence rates
uh and again echoing with some of the
stuff that came up earlier this morning
um
we can look at a very simple version of
reminding greater descent
and this is where uh you know we're
going to connect with the question about
the l smoothness you know the notion
that a function has
uh you know in euclidean space we often
study optimization problems where we
assume that the gradient of the function
is ellipses continuous
now
in euclidean space
the gradient of a function is ellipse is
continuous if and only if it satisfies
inequalities of this form
or the retraction would just be x plus s
so here
in order you know i'm just going to
assume that we have inequalities of this
form but involving the retraction
and this actually is is intimately
connected with the notion of having a
romanian lipstick continuous gradient
it's just that to define this properly i
would need parallel transports and
exponential maps and we're just not
going to go there today
um but but these inequalities here you
can think of them as really assuming l
smoothness but
in a differential geometric way
so i'm going to assume this with some
constant l
i'm going to assume that the function is
globally lower bounded
kind of whole manifold kind of makes
sense for optimization
we're going to look at this very simple
algorithm where you just retract the
negative gradient with constant 1 over l
you could replace this with line search
it just makes the proof a little bit
longer but it's the same
then the complexity result you get is
exactly the same as in the euclidean
case
namely that if you iterate this method
for capital k iterations
you encounter capital k points
each one of them has a gradient each one
of those gradients has a norm
one of them is smaller than everybody
else how small is it well it's not
bigger than this
and you know you see it decays like one
over root k
and and the constants here are exactly
the same as you had in euclidean case in
particular there's no dependence on
dimension of the manifold there's no
dependence on curvature of the manifold
which is a whole other story
the proof of this
is this is it that's the whole proof
and there's nothing geometric about it
it's just pure algebra
or you know just the manipulations of
you know inequalities is the same proof
as in the euclidean case there's nothing
about it everything geometric is hidden
in that assumption
okay
i'm out of time so let me just uh point
out that if you're interested in in
using these things
uh
on the software side uh
i would recommend uh just make it short
that you go to manu.org uh this is a
toolbox i've been working on in matlab
there's python and julia versions
developed by other people but
synchronize
um
and also at this address you can find
pointers to other toolboxes by other
people and they're all very good and so
you know this is a just a considered a
portal for resources about this topic
uh there's many active research
directions one i kind of like one i very
much like
is that it seems
that geometry and symmetry come up quite
a bit in
the phenomenon of benign non-convexity
which is going to
skip those slides enjoy the pictures
pockets of non-convexity where's the
tractability frontier
um
and there's very nice uh survey by um
zhang ku and wright this is john wright
from colombia where to talk about the
pervasiveness of geometry and symmetry
and benign non-convexity
and if you're interested to read more
about this topic
there's a the de facto reference book in
the field by abseil mahoney and sepulch
from 2008 you can get it for free at
this address
and uh i am also recently been working
on a book which you can also get for
free at this address and i thank you for
your time i'm happy to entertain any
questions if you have
thank you very much nicole for the great
talk uh are there any good questions
that people want to ask
uh yeah i guess you mentioned how the
optimization problem itself you know
doesn't come along with an intrinsic
rebody structure and this is something
that you impose separately uh could you
maybe give a remark on uh how how you
select what's it how you know it's an
appropriate structure to select for a
given problem or
yeah it's a it's a tough question right
to to know for for each it's like
preconditioning
you know you know from numerical in your
algebra how are you going to select a
good preconditioner to some extent it's
a it's an art
but there are certain metrics that you
can that you can look at to decide okay
is this better than that
and um
for example one thing you can look at is
um
so the local
convergence rates of methods like
gradient descent and others
ultimately is going to be uh dictated by
the condition number of the hessian at
your limit point so the condition number
of the remaining hessian at your limit
point
now
that is
directly a function of your choice of
remaining metric right because your
remaining hessian depends on the choice
of remaining metric so if you choose a
different romanian metric the condition
number might be different
and sometimes vastly so and this
actually connects also with something
ashad talked about which was a um i
think um she called it the hessian
manifold right where the the remaining
metric you pick on rn is actually the
hessian of a strongly convex function
um so
so there are certain things you can do
there to choose a metric that would
somehow for your application
have a positive effect on the condition
number of the remaining hessian at the
minimizer that's something you can you
can certainly do
um now beyond that
there are also just a
certain remaining metrics that for
example would make
um
would make the manifold complete we'll
see this presumably again i haven't seen
a series talk yet but i imagine this
will come up
if you optimize over the uh the positive
definite matrices
just the set of positive definite
matrices as a subset of symmetric
matrices is just an open set
uh and so it's not uh
if you think of it as a as an open set
in in the symmetric matrices it's not
the complete set it's not metrically
it's not complete so you might move
around and easily you know jump outside
of it
and this might cause some trouble when
you optimize
but there is a way um a very pleasant
way in fact to choose a different metric
on the positive definite matrices that
will make that set that manifold
complete in a metric sense but also in
the remaining sense
uh and this in fact has other
ramifications and um you know
it can help make algorithms behave more
nicely
thank you
so
i'm i'm trying to understand the the the
story you are trying to tell which is at
some point seem to conclude by once i've
set up all this manifold uh uh geometry
when i want to analyze them some
algorithms i'm basically just unfolding
the same computations that i would for
for uh uh well and that was the only one
but so the other thing that you know if
i do a parallel with you know
traditional convex optimization on fat
spaces
you seem to you know the statement the
other the statement that you showed us
the only complete result that we saw was
basically you know let's make some
general assumptions on class of
functions that we can tackle with the
same algorithm and uh my question is
does this
yield some results on like concrete
manifold with concrete loss functions
that we could not get by just like you
know rolling up our sleeves and going
straight at it
yes there are a couple of things here um
one is well i i did very much run out of
uh run out of time so there's much more
to say about this it's certainly the
case
that there are all sorts of interesting
optimization algorithm algorithms and
manifolds for which the analysis is not
just a
the euclidean analysis and you know just
uh make it go through there's more to it
than that and
and one aspect of it is uh to understand
you know that
the role that the remaining curvature
may or may not have on the complexity of
certain things
and um you know i i imagine again that
this may come up in in the next
presentation uh but for example
acceleration is a you know is a
fascinating uh uh topic where it seems
that
uh accelerating gradient descent on
negatively curved manifolds made out may
not actually be possible and so there
might actually be it's although i mean
it's a subtle question uh but there's
this very interesting uh preprint by
hamilton and mohitra
where um you know they make this case in
an interesting setup where you see that
there's an actual difference between
optimizing on curved spaces and
non-curved spaces and and this does come
up uh you know
in much of the more recent literature so
it's just a one aside now for the other
uh aspect of it which was you know you
were saying can we not just uh roll up
her sleeves and and go at it and uh you
know
head-on
um i'm not entirely sure uh what you
have in mind here
um but but do do you mean to say
like write out uh the optimization
algorithm on the manifold but ignore the
the geometry and just work out uh
um a complexity result uh by brute force
mostly talking about the analysis not
the algorithm design which obviously
yeah and what's going on with the
metaphor
i mean
uh definitely
but you can do this for everything right
you can always express everything uh
with the
you know just the basic uh logic uh
logical statements and hide all the
structure um i think in your experience
there's like
like savings or you know things become
more transparent once i actually work
with the everybody
yeah i would say so i would say so
definitely um
i mean if anything it provides a
framework in which to to think about
those things
and it also you know it allows you to
just like any mathematical theory you'll
have some general statements that allow
you to immediately know if something no
you're thinking might this be true if
you have a good sense of the general
theory then you might be
just a
capable of answering that question much
faster than you if you have to figure it
all out without any backup from any any
general framework
i don't know if that made a whole lot of
sense but
it does
i think we should let people go and the
federal break thank you again nicole
this was a really informative talk
and we will be back at uh 3 30 for the
talk by suvitstra let's pass
bye everyone hope to see you at some
point
bye